歡迎收看泛科學新聞
感謝另外一百位泛糰會員的加入
讓這個節目得以進入第三季
我們也將在本季展開內容改版
並固定每月一更慢科學
懇求還在考慮的你盡早加入
不管是每個月一顆飯糰、兩顆飯糰、五顆飯糰、
鮭魚飯糰、明太子飯糰、
還是菜脯蛋油條飯糰
都是幫我們繼續做好科學傳播的動力
多謝各位會員嘅支持
如果你看了上週
泛科學歲末晚餐直播
對 就是這集
肯定知道我們團隊正在積極徵才中
泛科學正在找科學內容編輯
歡迎不同專業背景
對科學知識有熱情
對跨媒體創作有經驗的夥伴
來跟我們聊聊
詳細資訊 請點下方資訊欄連結
也歡迎分享給求職的朋友
對了 要附上作品集喔
蛤？
沒有朋友啊
那 你可以分享
泛科學和教育出版權威南一書局
聯手推出的
科！學！生！
給你的親戚 建構科普素養
培養閱讀實力就從這本開始
點擊下方
PanSci 泛科學商店的第一個商品
現在有預購新書 79 折優惠喔
很多人以為刺青只是一點皮肉痛
不管是腳底的反清復明
還是額頭上的愛
墨水會乖乖地待在真皮層
當個安靜的藝術品
但剛發表在《PNAS》期刊的研究發現
刺青其實是獻祭的烙印
沒錯 雖然全球有將近 2 成的人刺青
而且科學家早就知道
刺青墨水會跑進淋巴結
也知道墨水裡有重金屬等污染物
會引起過敏和發炎
但這全程到底發生什麼事
沒人知道
直到現在
為了看清楚墨水在體內搞什麼鬼
瑞士科學家首先動用能Live 直播的
「活體雙光子顯微鏡」
這是一種利用高能量紅外光脈衝的
先進成像技術
不需要把老鼠切開
也不用破壞組織
就能直接穿透皮膚
即時觀察活體深層細胞的動態
而這 Live 是一場名副其實的「蝕」之刻
就在刺青針刺下去的短短 10 分鐘內
奈米級的墨水顆粒
彷彿被召喚的使徒
成群結隊湧入淋巴管
直衝免疫核心「淋巴結」
但衝進去之後呢
這時就換另一台負責「驗屍」的
「穿透式電子顯微鏡」登場
跟剛剛看動態的不一樣
它用電子束去穿透超薄的細胞切片
專門觀察細胞內部的超微結構
在高解析度定格畫面下
科學家看到了慘烈的案發現場
淋巴結裡的「巨噬細胞」
原本像鷹之團一樣勇
現在卻死狀淒慘
畫面顯示
巨噬細胞塞滿了剛剛吞進去的黑色異物
細胞膜已經起泡、破裂
呈現出典型的「壞死」狀態
為了計算傷亡
科學家接著拿出「流式細胞儀」
能吸入細胞懸浮液
讓細胞一顆一顆排隊通過雷射檢驗
精準判讀細胞的死活
數據顯示 這是一場單方面的虐殺
巨噬細胞發生了大規模的「凋亡」(Apoptosis)
與「壞死」(Necrosis)
更絕望的是
巨噬細胞死後
肚子裡的墨水會爆出來
被新趕來的巨噬細胞吞掉
接著新細胞又中毒死亡
淋巴結就這樣陷入了
長達兩個月的死亡輪迴
慢性發炎
在這個 moment
如果他剛好又去打疫苗呢
科學家發現
如果打的是 mRNA 新冠疫苗
效果會大打折扣
因為 mRNA 疫苗需要巨噬細胞幫忙
在細胞表面製造並展示病毒的「棘蛋白」
來訓練免疫軍隊
但遭到墨水攻擊的巨噬細胞正忙著
或已經死了一片
沒力氣展示棘蛋白
結果抗體反應顯著下降
舉不起名為免疫力的「斬龍劍」
難道在這因果律的螺旋中
只有毀滅
誒 科學家發現
如果打的是「滅活流感疫苗」
效果竟然變強了
這就像穿上「狂戰士鎧甲」
雖然淋巴結正在發炎
正被名為「細胞激素」的憎恨吞噬
但失控的發炎反應
反而充當了「佐劑」(Adjuvant)的角色
強化了對抗流感病毒的殺意
讓免疫系統殺紅了眼
所以刺青墨水不只是皮膚上的畫
它能召喚災厄
讓免疫系統陷入混亂
也能在某些時刻
透過痛苦換取力量
蛤
你真的把烙印刺在身上
誒 古力菲斯他在這
你渴望力量嗎
那就罵髒話吧
是的
根據英國基爾大學與美國阿拉巴馬大學團隊
發表在《美國心理學家》的最新研究指出
罵髒話 能顯著提升人類的體能極限
他們找來三百個受試者
進行體能之巔挑戰
受試者必須先坐在椅子上
然後用雙手撐起全身重量
讓屁股跟腳完全懸空
直到肌肉崩潰為止
實驗分成兩組
一組人要每兩秒唸一個 無聊的中性詞
例如「桌子」、「沙發」
就像我在逛 IKEA
另一組人則被允許
每兩秒鐘就噴出一句
自己選的髒話
結果髒話組的支撐時間
顯著變長
戰鬥力 Plus Ultra
但要怎麼確定這背後的機制
畢竟我們不能把受試者的腦袋剖開來看
真的不能
所以研究使用
「中介分析」(Mediation Analysis)
在實驗過程中
同時蒐集了三組數據
分別你是有沒有罵髒話、
你當下的心理分數、
以及你撐了幾秒
當然 關於心理分數
不是一邊懸空還要咬著筆作答
那真的連髒話都罵不出
蛤
還有別的地方可以握筆
實驗採用的是「即時回溯測量」
受試者是在撐不住倒下
任務結束的賢者時間
立刻填寫量表
經過三百人的數據分析
科學家抓到了三個
讓髒話變成 Buff 的關鍵路徑
第一 分心
髒話轉移了注意力
讓人忽略肌肉要斷的痛苦
第二 自信
罵出來的瞬間
人們覺得自己是老大
區區一張椅子算什麼
第三 心流
是的 髒話竟然能讓人進入
「Zone」的狀態
這三個加起來就形成了一種
「狀態去抑制」(State Disinhibition)
也就是說 大腦平常會設下一個「安全閥」
怕我們受傷
但一句 6 字髒話
就像把這個安全閥給駭掉了
讓你
はぁ？うっせぇうっせぇうっせぇわ
あなたが思うより健康です
但罵髒話有效
會不會是因為打破禁忌的感覺很好笑
讓人放鬆呢
雖然這次受試者都承認
罵髒話當下覺得很好笑
但是統計結果證明
幽默分數的高低
跟能撐多久沒有關係
要心裡覺得自己很強（自信）、很專心（心流）
才有用
那那那 如果平常每天都
ㄇㄉㄈㄎ
這招還有用嗎
其實團隊的 Richard Stephens 教授
早在 2009 年 就因為發現罵髒話能止痛
而拿過搞笑諾貝爾獎
但到了 2011 年 他們進一步發現
要是整天髒話掛在嘴邊
罵髒話的止痛效果確實會變差
就像喝咖啡喝到有抗藥性一樣
這在科學上叫做「習慣化」
不過呢 根據這次分析
力量提升來自於自信和心流
所以就算有人平常嘴就髒
但在極限挑戰時
髒話依然是強力的心理開關
能瞬間集中注意力
就像怪奇物語裡人見人愛 Derek
面對 Vecna 飆髒話
其實是在進行科學化的自我增強
透過語言觸發大腦的去抑制機制
瞬間拉高自信
做出超乎常人的表現
研究的共同作者
Nicholas Washmuth 甚至表示
他們接下來要研究罵髒話
對公開演講和戀愛搭訕有沒有幫助
結果怎樣令人好奇
但我想對開直播收錢
應該是蠻有幫助
你知唔知我老竇係邊個呀？
對 最愛講這句話的不是富二代或官二代
而是古人類學家
他們為了這根骨頭
吵了二十多年
這就是 2001 年
在撒哈拉沙漠南緣半乾燥地帶出土的
「沙赫人猿」(Sahelanthropus)
綽號「圖邁」(Toumaï)
在當地語言中是指
出生在乾季剛開始時的孩子
自從它出土以來
古人類學界就分裂成兩派
一派堅持它是人類最早的直立祖先
另一派反批這只是一隻普通的黑猩猩
紐約大學領導的團隊
決定讓 AI 來當話事人
在《Science Advances》上
刊登的最新研究中
他們用了 ALPACA
不是草泥馬
這技術全名是
「自動點雲對齊分析」(Automated Landmarking through Point cloud Alignments)
這是一種電腦視覺技術
團隊把沙赫人猿的骨頭
連同 266 根 來自現代人、黑猩猩、大猩猩
還有「露西」這類明星化石的股骨
全部掃描成高解析度的 3D 模型
接著 ALPACA 自動在這些骨頭上
打上成千上萬個定位點
一點一點把骨頭繪製出來
徹底消除了人類手抖或偏見的誤差
這讓 AI 抓到了一個關鍵證據
「股骨結節」(Femoral Tubercle)
各位請現在就站起來
摸一下你的
算了 不要亂摸
總之當你站直的時候
你的髖關節不會往前垮掉
是因為有條超粗的「髂股韌帶」拉住你
這條韌帶就像是 Gunpla 模型關節裡的卡榫
讓你不用耗費肌肉力量
就能維持站姿
這是人類獨有的「被動技能」
在黑猩猩身上這個位置是平滑的
但在沙赫人猿七百萬年前的老骨頭上
ALPACA 確認了那個粗糙的突起
證明它已經取得「省力直立行走」的技能
而且數據還顯示它的股骨有詭異的
「前扭轉」(Antetorsion)
說它詭異
是因為猿類的大腿骨通常是往後扭的
但沙赫人猿已經開始往內旋轉
所以我們才不用像唐老鴨那樣走
但但但
雖然他的腿很誠實地想當人
它的手還是很野獸
針對他那根跟四魂之玉一樣
裂得亂七八糟的手骨（尺骨）
團隊使出數位鏡像技術
在電腦裡把碎片拼湊成完整的骨頭
分析顯示
這隻手的彎曲度跟強壯程度
跟黑猩猩一模一樣
這說明沙赫人猿處於特殊的中間態
它一邊是個搖搖晃晃的雙足行走者
但只要一聽到掠食者的聲音
或者單純想偷懶
能馬上切換回攀爬模式
跑酷上樹
蛤
你也會跑酷
在臺灣走人行道是吧
這發現讓我們更看清人類的演化
絕非一次到位
而是一個漫長的、拼裝的過程
七百萬年前的祖先
雖然腦袋只有我們三分之一
但它確實已經為了看更遠的舞台
或是為了騰出雙手拿手燈
挺起了腰桿
嗯
史上第一次啊
科學家成功量測到一顆
「流浪行星」的精確質量與距離
由中國北京大學科維理研究所
聯手波蘭、韓國與歐洲太空總署的跨國團隊
透過「天地連線」
精準抓到了流浪行星的身高體重
跟「戶籍地址」
研究剛刊登在《Science》上
很多人可能知道
我們人類已經發現好幾千顆系外行星了
但流浪行星不一樣
它不發光、無恆星、無軌道
我們明明知道他們在
卻沒辦法用 凌日法 或 徑向速度法
套公式把數據算出來
彷彿在暗處嗆聲
You don’t know about me
讓 Scientist 都
S-s psycho, s-s-s-s psycho
唯一的辦法只有愛因斯坦留下的外掛
「微重力透鏡效應(Gravitational Microlensing)」
就是當這顆看不見的流浪行星
剛好飄過一顆遙遠背景恆星的前面時
它的質量會把時空稍微掰彎
像放大鏡一樣
短暫地把背景恆星的光聚焦、放大
如果我們湊巧看到那顆背景恆星
突然變亮又暗下來
就是行星的證據
但這方法有個 Bug
叫做「質量-距離簡併」(Mass-Distance Degeneracy)
你想
要是在漆黑的隧道裡
看到遠方有個亮點
你很難判斷那是很遠的
大卡車車燈
還是很近的
拿著兩顆金球的高速婆婆
單靠地面望遠鏡
看微重力透鏡效應也是一樣
分不清楚是「很近的小石頭」
還是「很遠的大塊頭」
所以以前發現的流浪行星
數據都是 大概、可能、也許
而這次突破關鍵是 視差
你現在閉上左眼用右眼看手指
然後交換
手指位置會跳動對吧
這就是
瞬間移動
痾 不是
是「雙眼視覺」原理
而科學家這次請出了三眼
兩隻是來自波蘭的OGLE (光學重力透鏡實驗)
和韓國的 KMTNet 望遠鏡
嗯？
組成的地面組
他們聯手死盯著銀河系
確保不漏接變亮的訊號
第三隻眼是來自歐洲太空總署的蓋亞衛星
位於距離地球150 萬公里的
L2 拉格朗日點
當三眼同時盯著那顆行星看
因為距離夠遠 (150 萬公里)
光線抵達的時間產生了微小的時差
科學家抓住了這個瞬間
終於用三角測量
解算出它的精確距離
但這整件事最難的倒不是技術
而是運氣
蓋亞衛星不是指哪看哪
而是一直旋轉掃描全天空
這次的事件發生時
蓋亞的掃描路徑
剛好垂直切過這個區域
而且在短短的關鍵 16 小時內
剛好掃了這顆行星 6 次
連論文作者都承認這是一抽入魂
要是早一點、晚一點或角度偏一點
蓋亞就會完美錯過
回到單眼瞎猜
這顆代號 OGLE-2024-BLG-0516 的流浪者
距離我們約一萬光年
質量跟土星差不多
因為它飛得太快
科學家推測它原本可能住在一個聯星系統
但因為裡頭兩個大人吵架、重力擾動
小孩就被轟了出來 浪跡天涯
雖然只驗明一顆流浪行星
但這證明「太空視差法」
行得通
而接下來要上太空的 NASA 羅曼望遠鏡
它的巡天速度比哈伯快 1000 倍
預計能用微重力透鏡
找到成千上萬顆流浪行星
讓我們徹底搞懂行星如何形成
又為何離開家門
蛤？
你說會不會是被某個宇宙大國派兵綁架帶走
大概、可能、也許
想解決塑膠問題
有辦法了
我可不是說現在市面上的可分解塑膠
那大多是笑話
要嘛做得超硬超耐用
變成萬年垃圾
要嘛做得超容易分解
沒多久就壞
還得再買
但美國羅格斯大學的科學家
在《Nature Chemistry》上
剛發表了一項突破
能讓塑膠
用的時陣硬拚拚
īng ê sî-tsūn ngē-piānn-piānn
無用的時陣散甲無影無跡
bô-īng ê sî-tsūn, sàn-kah bô-iáⁿ bô-tsiah
這群科學家在爬山的時候
看著滿地塑膠垃圾 心想
欸 不是
DNA 是聚合物
蛋白質是聚合物
塑膠也是聚合物
憑什麼大自然的聚合物
時間到會自己乖乖分解
而我們造的塑膠卻賴著不走
他們驚訝的發現
關鍵不在於材料本身有多爛
而是大自然在蓋 DNA 時
就把炸藥埋在樑柱旁
這叫「構象預組織」
(Conformational Preorganization)
簡單來說
因為我也只能簡單說
如果我們把塑膠分子看成一棟房子
那個支撐結構的「磷酸三酯鍵」
就是這棟房子的樑柱
而那個能破壞結構的「羥基」
就是黃色炸藥
因此羅格斯團隊決定抄襲大自然的作業
設計多款結構
第一種 M1 是對照組
就像是用一條軟趴趴的繩子
把炸藥跟樑柱綁在一起
但因為繩子太長太軟
炸藥大部分時間都在空氣中
晃來晃去
根本貼不到樑柱
所以引爆率極低
第二種 M2 是一個五邊形的環狀牢房
科學家把炸藥跟樑柱鎖進去
但故意鎖成反方向
也就是背對背
這下好了
雖然距離拉近了
但炸藥的引信完全朝向相反的方向
這叫做反式構象
結果這款塑膠比第一種更硬
完全死不了
第三種 M3 同樣的牢房
但這次把炸藥轉過來
就像抱著淀治的蕾潔
呈現一種曖昧的鄰位交叉姿勢
只要一有機會
馬上就能動手
數據顯示
這種設計的自毀速度
是第一種的 160 倍
但這樣還不夠快
科學家想要一種瞬間蒸發的效果
於是 Makima 登場
這是一種叫做降冰片烷(Norbornane) 的骨架
是一個剛性超強的雙環結構
把炸藥跟樑柱死死固定在完全重疊的角度
也就是重疊構象
在這種設計下
炸藥和引信是完美貼合的
完全沒有任何猶豫或逃脫的空間
結果就是
這種結構的自毀速度
比軟趴趴的第一種
快了整整三千三百倍
那那那要怎麼控制它何時自毀
科學家設計了兩種保險
第一種是光
給炸藥裝個安全插梢
也就是鄰硝基苄基保護基
一照紫外線 插梢噴飛
炸藥立刻引爆
第二種更猛 是用金屬離子
原本房子可能是展開的
炸藥離樑柱有點距離
但只要加入鋇離子
整棟房子就摺疊起來
剛好把炸藥貼到樑柱上
BOOM！
這項技術最猛的地方在於
它不需要高溫
也不用強酸強鹼
在一般的環境就能發生
這意味著未來的塑膠
可以像阿湯哥收到的訊息一樣
將在五秒後自動銷毀
喝完手搖飲
杯子照個光就化成灰
要是這個發明能一舉擊敗塑膠惡魔
那就太好了
你覺得有機會嗎？
你有哪些東西
需要用這種能自毀的材料製作呢
你還是不要說好了
重力波只能「遠觀」？
德國亥姆霍茲德勒斯登-羅森多夫
研究中心的科學家
現在想直接褻玩
這項剛發表在《物理評論快報》的研究
提出一個非常瘋狂
但對物理學家很正常的計畫
用雷射光去「偷」重力波的能量
或者反過來
幫重力波「賦能」
這怎麼可能
要搞懂
得先致敬一位悲情的先驅
約瑟夫·韋伯 (Joseph Weber)
六十年前
他搞了一個幾噸重的巨大金屬鋁棒
想透過鋁棒的共振來偵測重力波
結果....
嗯
爭議很大
最後沒成功
但這根以他為名的韋伯棒
仍讓他獲得重力波探測之父的名號
這次亥姆霍茲中心的科學家
乾脆捨棄笨重的金屬棒
用「光」來做一根棒子
這就是「光學韋伯棒」
結構有點像現在的 LIGO
但是這根更變態
他們打算在一個約一公里長的裝置裡
利用反射鏡
讓雷射脈衝瘋狂來回反射
把有效光路拉長到整整「一百萬公里」
原理就像盪鞦韆
想像重力波是正在盪的鞦韆
雷射光是在一旁推鞦韆的人
在那邊那魯 One、那魯 Two、
那魯 Three、那魯 Four、
那魯 7-11
如果雷射光推的時機剛好 頻率對上
就能把能量灌給重力波
這叫「受激輻射」
重力波會變強一點點
反過來 推的方向跟鞦韆相反
就會把鞦韆的能量吸過來
重力波變弱
而雷射光自己變強
但為什麼要這麼累
LIGO 不是已經把事辦完了嗎
Well
雖然 LIGO 告訴我們
「空間在震動」
卻沒辦法告訴我們
重力到底是什麼組成的
物理學家一直懷疑重力是由一顆顆
「重力子 (Graviton)」組成的
如果真能測量到雷射光
和重力波交換能量
而且這能量是一份一份
不能再分割的
就等於「重力子」存在的鐵證
這可是物理學的聖杯啊
為了抓到這 SSSSSSR 訊號
科學家還得開外掛
使用一種量子絕招
叫做「NOON 態」
這個名字其實是它的長相
N-0-0-N
這裡的 N 代表所有的光子
0 代表沒有光子
一般的雷射光經過分光鏡
就像是沒紀律的觀光客
一半走左邊 一半走右邊
但 NOON 態的光子是多重影分身
而且有「蜂群意識」
處於極度糾纏的狀態
要嘛全部 N 顆光子都走左邊、
要嘛全部都走右邊
注意 在量子世界裡
這兩個選項是「同時發生」的
全都在左邊
也同時全部在右邊
如果重力波稍微推一下光
讓光稍微變了一點
相位改變
在 NOON 態下
因為所有 N 顆光子綁定在一起
只要其中一顆感覺到變化
整個 N 顆光子大部隊
就會同時反應
讓訊號靈敏度放大 N 倍
這就是傳說中的「海森堡極限」
物理學上最精準的測量極限
不過實驗的挑戰真的很誇張
一百萬公里干涉儀就算能成
只要鏡子稍微有一點震動
或者路徑上有一顆灰塵
一點點雜訊弄丟了一顆光子
整個 NOON 態就會瞬間崩潰(Decoherence)
實驗報銷
但如果成功了
我們就不再只是宇宙的「旁觀者」
而是第一次獲得「操縱」重力的能力
就算規模小、就算只能蹭
當然 這目前就只是篇論文
但科學家說
用現有的技術是有機會做到的
對 科學家常常這麼說
但他們也常常做到
不是嗎
以上就是本週的泛科學新聞
如果你喜歡今天的內容
或對哪一則新聞想黜臭
歡迎在下面留言
也別忘了訂閱、按讚、開啟小鈴鐺
下週繼續發現這世界有多荒唐
如果你有拍到什麼比巨大的韋伯好棒棒
還壯觀的背景圖
歡迎投稿喔
詳情請看下方的資訊欄